[Musik]
silber kann noch nico was ist da los
ich musste bei meinen eltern schon
wieder einen sprachkurs vorschieben
was tut mir leid sie werden sehr wütend
wenn sie herausfinden wo ich wirklich
bin
ich bin froh so trotzdem kaum bist ich
freue mich auf dich zu finden ein moment
nicht bewegen
alles gute zum geburtstag ich habe das
gefühl du kannst es brauchen
[Musik]
ich bin so glücklich war ein schönes
fördert ist das wirklich für mich
das fahrrad ist toll und wenn meine
eltern fragen welches haben wenn deine
eltern freien sehr dass hass und sagt
einfach es ist von lisa aber wenn meine
eltern sich bei ihr für das fahrrad
bedanken damit sie sich doch wundern
lisa reese bescheid und heute nachmittag
darf ich eislaufen gehen
das hat das erlaubt der besten sechs
seiten lang